une production du studio sfr
[Musique]
bienvenue au sans fil dans le podcast où
on parle aussi avec nos invités dadis
itx ph quentin avec moins d'hommes
plante si vous le saviez pas on a une
page fait fuir noës qu'on dépose tous
les podcasts qu'on enregistre al avance
donc en ce moment pendant qu'on se parle
sur la page futur ni le podcast avec
cimetière du lude ludovic bourgeois
anthony bertrand grenier qui viennent
qui est venu nous parler en fait de la
différence entre les croyances et la
connaissance en plus des podcasts en
avance on fait là encore moins de
filtres ou est ce qu'après chaque pas de
gaston parle même à 30 minutes nicole
d'hommes puis - fille elle s'est excusée
formant des trous en fait si vous voulez
allez vous abonner trois pièces par mois
vous avez accès à tous à aller voir que
je suis en réception en fait si nomme
cette semaine fait semaine grand plaisir
de recevoir julien touré qui viennent
nous expliquer le conflit en afghanistan
la guerre en afghanistan depuis 20 ans
le contexte tous ceux qui sont les
talibans pic et qu'est ce qui s'est
passé dernièrement qu'est ce qui fait
que les talibans ont pris contrôle du
pays qu'est-ce qu'on peut projeter dans
l'avenir pour ce pays là vraiment
comprendre tout ce contexte le puits je
peux parler pour moi puis je pense pour
plusieurs ça a vraiment été dur a permis
de vraiment comprendre mieux toute cette
situation le kiki peut être complexe est
un peu flou la guerre comment ces mots
gt et gt t-il beaucoup de mots qui nous
écoutent qui qui s'est étonné dans la
gare et comment c'est carrément donc
julien qui chercheurs sur la politique
américaine la politique internationale
qui a un doctorat en sciences politiques
qui enseigne et grands à l'université
c'était vraiment un grand cours
magistral site est clair c'était comme
si c'était précis vraiment un énorme
merci à lui devenu désertique et dessous
tout à fait puis juste avant d'aller à
la conversation va les remercier nos
commanditaires oui le podcast est
présenté par auch lag qui continuent
leur partenariat avec le studio sf qui
devient le fournisseur en fait qui reste
le fournisseur officiel d'alcool et de
en fait de jean de bière et de ces
religieux de produits alcoolisés du
studio sf donc si vous venez loué le
studio et soeurs on offre les boissons
alcoolisées hochelaga de façon
complémentaire ils viennent toujours
dans la soul nouvelle gamme de panneaux
de la nano blonde rivière plus mon
trépas ce moment si tous avoir un petit
rythme et équitable potro c'est une
bière extra est extrait les gens c'est
2,5 pour cent d'alcool jusqu'à légitime
m aussi plus léger en termes de calories
de ces temps ci il fait chaud on goûte
quelque chose qui rafraîchit qui ferait
qu'il funky froid qui permet de prendre
ce d'heure d'ailleurs c'est le mode ou
apprendra que le moule plus chaud de
l'histoire de québec sans quelqu'un de
phan fah pis dans ces moments-là des
canicules une bonne claque danos a fait
le job y at-il donc la nano à épier la
nano blonde la nano blanche en plus de
tous leurs produits chez qui on avait
déjà parlé beaucoup la circulation sur
un lot de bonnes options qui fait
tourner même si kruger pour la new
england piégée juste devant moi 5 merci
beaucoup à claques de ce partenariat la
csu par la fenêtre avec bobby à ceux qui
nous écoutent cours et procurer des
produits halal
g où le podcast est présenté par memscap
medicare les connaissances a fait
plusieurs longtemps qu'ils nous
commandites il nous aime on les adore on
utilise leurs produits je pense que même
leurs tee-shirts aujourd'hui teichmann
skype puis j'en ai plusieurs touches
augmenté en plus pierre magnan n'est
laissée entraîner chez mes parents
qui ma mère c'est là qu'apparaît tasigna
façon jardinage à kingfisher écrit le
bal où il peine ku sur son chemin sans
savoir trop ce que ça voulait dire
jusqu'à quel genre il ya de la visite
qui arrive qui m'ont dit
qu'ils avaient compris qu'un portait un
t-shirt et de rasoirs pourqoui memscap
ph ouais en fait moi et on vous parle
souvent tu peux fait craquer le 4.0 avec
le lendemain 4.0 qui est l'ultime
creepers pour sous la ceinture puis on
vous pendant appartement suivante est un
peu devenu un running gag d'un ami de ma
soeur en fait le monde pas de du fait
que j'ai les couilles prop en fait à
travers ses amis puis jusqu'au point où
est ce que j'avais un peu fait package
4.0 ce que vous avez ici de ce qui vient
avec le le
le lower plus des d'autres produits pour
l'entretien sous la ceinture
que j'en ai amené un bon ami j'ai dit en
effet le tard et trop de rire de moi
comme de fait et c'est la meilleur
produit que j'ai utilisé pour
m'entretenir les boys l'essayer c'est
l'adopter - fait qu'ils ont le perfect
hackett et 4.0 qui sion le
drame a dit gagner pour aller dans les
régions plus difficiles d'accès l'été
puis
pour être sûr d'avoir le
boss du plus court c'est moins urgent
sous lion des du parfum des bons wild
tout le kit on a un code promo pour vous
qui le sans fil wingles 20% de rabais
plus livraison gratuite fait que si vous
avez des boys ou une personne qui vous
donne un cadeau à des boys
pensé mon skate vous n'allez jamais le
regretter merci la gamme chez mindscape
bibeau au caire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
good je viens mais recettes le
sait vraiment c'est vraiment fun sans
plus super rapide comme comme boucle ont
été écrits puis une semaine plus tard on
en rit je sais c'est parfait parce que
dans des situations comme comme en ce
moment comme ce qui se passe en
afghanistan c'est intéressant de pouvoir
en parler quand ça réussit pas trop
longtemps après mathon oui même si quand
on est vraiment dans l'actualité la plus
brûlante ça évolue quasiment de jour en
jour dans un cas aussi à analyser des
fois chose c'est pas évident mais il ya
quand même quelques clés de lecture qui
permettent de comprendre si cette
actualité très très brûlante est très
très très fluide comme on la voit en ce
moment-même enfin encore aujourd'hui
vous avez des développements marquant à
kaboul donc je pense avec plaisir des
cas je pense très intéressant
aujourd'hui de traiter certains
développements lopy de vraiment la
situation présente sais quoi mais c'est
par un bon retour sur
la guerre en afghanistan et qui sont les
talibans pourquoi y ait une guerre pour
que les états unis sont venus pourquoi
son parti toutes ces questions il
pourrait vraiment essayer de comprendre
parce que témoin en préparant pour le
podcast évidemment j'ai lu un peu puis
je me suis informé un peu plus sur le
pourquoi du comment de guerre leur
métier je pense que comme comme beaucoup
en suivant l'actualité de manière un peu
semi passive des fois il ya beaucoup de
détails qui nous échappe finalement
comprend pas vraiment
ce sujet comme très complexe ou six
employés en plus mettons suppôts
l'actualité de façon semi passive
tétouan dessus quand cette façon
assidûment puis moi aussi puis on ya
quand même beaucoup de détails qu'on a
manqué au fil des années ce qui est un
bon c'est
un bon retour si elle comprend d'aider
les détails de ce conflit là je pense
que on va être plusieurs à avoir besoin
que je penserais très bien effective je
vais essayer de
laisser tout une commande
premièrement fait première question
comment est ce que on est arrivé à avoir
l'ingérence des autres pays en abyme
stains initialement
pour la phase peut-être qui nous
intéresse le plus immédiatement pour
comprendre
les conséquences du retrait des troupes
américaines tel qu'on le voit depuis
quelques jours depuis quelques semaines
il faut se rappeler qu'elle les
américains donc s'il se retire c'est
qu'ils sont arrivés sans perdre je vois
là ils sont arrivés il ya de ça presque
vingt ans jour pour jour au lendemain
des attentats terroristes du 11
septembre 2001 à new york à washington
et en pennsylvanie
l'administration du président de
l'époque george w bush a décidé de
répondre à ses attentes à la en attaque
en afghanistan parce que il avait été
établi que le commanditaire l'architecte
de ces attentats du 11 septembre 2001
oussama ben laden et son organisation
terroriste al-qaïda et est établie avait
un sanctuaire en afghanistan et que le
régime qui était alors en place donc
l'autorité politique si je puis dire qui
dirigeait l'afghanistan qui contrôlent l
afghanistan cette époque là le régime
des taliban avaient ou a refusé au
lendemain du 11 septembre 2001 de livrer
oussama ben laden aux américains donc en
réponse aux attentats george w bush dit
baye les talibans n'ont pas voulu nous
donner ben laden ils sont co
responsables des attentats donc on
intervient pour les chasser et
idéalement pour se faire justice
c'est-à-dire
tué oussama ben laden ça c'est la raison
première de l'implication des etats-unis
en afghanistan dont qu'elle dure depuis
20 ans dans l'histoire des états unis
c'était la guerre la plus longue de par
sa durée et ça explique aussi cette
motivation initiale qui est grosso modo
se faire justice après des attentats
toutes les difficultés qui ont été
rencontrés par après parce que on pourra
peut-être y revenir mais il faut
d'emblée avoir à l'esprit que l'objectif
américain en afghanistan à ce moment là
il est très limité encore une fois se
faire justice donc chasser les méchants
un peu comme le shérif va attraper les
délinquants
ce n'est pas de construire initialement
un afghanistan qui soit un pays stable
et prospère avec des valeurs qui
ressemblerait
aux valeurs démocratiques on va revenir
précisément le la raison pourquoi est ce
que cette mission américaine a changé en
cours de route mais pour expliquer le
concept politique en afghanistan
ou est ce que c'est les talibans qui
gouverne un bain au début 2000 quelle
est la situation pour le politique la
boxe qu'est ce que les taliban de quelle
façon les gouvernants du magic c'est pas
des élections franches j'imagine qu'il
ya des caisses qui se passe à 20 que les
américains cible alors les talibans
soient au pouvoir en afghanistan depuis
1996 donc relativement peu de temps se
voulait avant les attentats du 11
septembre 2001 et eux émerge d'une
situation de conflit parce que si on
prend sont élargies si vous voulez la
frise historique au delà de 20 ans et
qu'on multiplie par deux camps on va
jusqu'à 40 ans grosso modo de
l'afghanistan est en guerre depuis 1979
le tout bien sûr voilà en guerre civile
avec l'implication d'une autre puissance
étrangère l'ancien super puissance de la
guerre froide à partir de 79 jusqu'en
1989 qui était l'union soviétique bon
les soviétiques se retire en 1989 le
régime qu'ils appuyaient à kaboul
s'écroule trois ans plus tard en 1992 et
dans la période de 92 à 96
il ya tout d'abord chez les différents
partis et différents groupes ethniques
afghan une tentative de coexistence de
partage du pouvoir sauf que assez
rapidement ça fonctionne pas
il y a des divergences il y à des
affrontements la population perçoit ces
nouvelles entités gouvernementales comme
inefficace et corrompue et si vous
voulez c'est dans ce contexte de chaos
qui émergent en particulier dans le sud
de l'afghanistan au sein de l'ethnie
pachtoune ce mouvement d'idées des
talibans qui initialement leur promet
deux choses finalement la population
afghane
l'orne
et la justice
alors petit à petit ils vont prendre le
pouvoir notamment à partir de 94 95 et
96 ils vont conquérir kaboul évidemment
l'ordre qu'ils proposent ils et la
justice sont fondés sur la charia sur la
loi islamique
en ce sens c'est vrai que ce sont des
intégristes ou qui ont une vision à tout
le moins très rigoriste de l'islam dans
sa version sunnites et
on se souvient peut-être dans les années
90 qu'elle soit au pouvoir
il écarte les femmes de la vie publique
voit même des rues complètement avec
dont le symbole de cet effacement des
femmes c'est le port obligatoire de la
burqa qui quand même un vêtement assez
oppressif c'est quand qu'on le regarde
ils interdisent le cinéma la musique un
autre dessin des symboles qui avait été
évoqué c'est l'interdiction pour les
enfants de jouer au cerf-volant dans les
rues des villes et villages afghans ils
ont détruit des des sculptures
bouddhiste
je sais plus exactement quelle année
mais des fois je parle à la même heure
sur les dates exactes mais ça ça avait
frappé la communauté internationale
parce qu'on avait saccagé l'une des
sculptures qui était peut-être pas
encore au patrimoine de l'unesco mais il
y avait une résonance importante
population afghane qui est bouddhiste ou
s'est dit non non non c'était des
vestiges historiques du fait de la
position de l'afghanistan mais donc de
96 à 2000 heures il impose un régime
voilà qui est hyper rigoriste évidemment
sur la place des femmes qui est loin
d'être favorable il reste une poche de
résistance à moi ce sera si minime au
final par rapport aux talibans qui vont
occuper à peu près 80 90 % du territoire
et avant vont quand même avoir un appui
de la population alors depuis plus ou
moins forcé
on s'entend
mais la résistance elle va être incarnée
par
le commandant massoud ahmad shah massoud
qui alors lui émergent sur la scène
politique afghane dès les années 80
parce que cela ne c'est fameux
moudjahidine que les américains ont aidé
contre la présence des soviétiques enfin
en afghanistan et il est à la tête à
partir du milieu des années 90 de ce
qu'on appelle l'alliance du nord dans le
nord du pays qui 2,96 à 2001 de façon
assez régulière mais sans réussir à
renverser le pouvoir de force va
harceler le pouvoir des talibans à
kaboul et il ya deux éléments très
intéressants par rapport à cette
résistance incarné par l'alliance du
nord est et massoud le premier c'est que
les talibans sont très conscients de la
capacité de massoud a fédéré autour de
lui et avoir un appui international et
les talibans sont conscients al qaïda
d'oussama ben laden aussi en est très
conscient il ne faut pas oublier que
quelques jours même quelques heures à
peine après les attentats du 11
septembre 2001 massoud est assassiné en
afghanistan dans le cadre d'un attentat
suicide mené par des gens d'al qaïda et
ça c'est une façon vraiment de sceller
l'alliance entre les talibans et al
qaïda cette information est vraiment
intéressante puis c'est la première fois
que j'entends ce que j'entends que le
leader de la
résistance
quelques quelques jours après leurs 800
cc à quelques jours avant donc c'est le
9 septembre
2001 le 9 ou le 10 septembre en décalage
horaire la jeu c'était vraiment un plan
coordonné pour clément changer le
paysage politique totalement toute cette
période la partie des 11 septembre c'est
attendre l'heure c'est oui et c'était
cet assassinat de massoud pour al qaïda
et pour ben laden encore une fois c'est
vraiment ce qui ce qui vient sceller
l'alliance alors il ya il a fait
d'autres choses un ben laden et son
organisation al-qaïda à partir du moment
où ils ont pu s'implanter en a ghani
strauss en même temps que l'arrivée des
talibans si vous voulez au milieu des
années 90 notamment des mariages plus ou
moins forcé lendemain puisque mois
entre combattants
d'al-qaïda et proches des talibans donc
en créer une symbiose à tel point que
les deux organisations au final elles se
confondent et vous avez ce premier
élément est cet élément marquant 20
majeur qu'est l'assassinât de massoud
parce que si vous voulez pour résumer
pour caricaturer ben laden dit aux
talibans bargach des jeux vous êtes
débarrassé
du principal opposant qui
d'ici quelques jours
voilà avoir la plus internationale
pourrait avoir l'appui international et
vous chassez donc les talibans si elles
deux jours voilà centre voulant dire
fallait pas que vendre le punch mais
sa selle sa selle l'alliance et par
après et évidemment ça explique pourquoi
les talibans refusent de le livrer sauf
que belle alliance du nord de feu le
commandant massoud existe encore et au
final les américains initialement vont
s'appuyer ils vont appuyer à l'aide de
forces spéciales et d'agents de la cia
cette alliance du nord qui va être le
fer de lance à partir du 7 octobre 2001
de l'opération qui a pour financement
pour objectif pour finalité de chasser
al qaïda et les talibans al qaïda qui
sont basés aussi en organe stains alors
al qaïda est terne afghanistan oui
depuis le milieu des années 90 un ben
laden se déplace alors il avait été dans
la corne
de l'afrique bon parce qu'ils étaient
chassés d'arabie saoudite un
nationalité saoudienne avait été
répudiée à ben laden parce que l'un de
ses objectifs initiaux à ben laden
s'était pas nécessairement d'attaquer
les états unis s'étaient de renverser le
régime corrompu en arabie saoudite et de
renverser d'autres régimes corrompus
dans le monde arabo musulman
mais au bout d'un moment dans sa logique
dans sa réflexion il s'est dit ben
j'arrive pas à déstabiliser ces régimes
l'a donc la meilleure chose que je
pourrais faire ça serait de déstabiliser
le principal soutien de ce régime là à
savoir la puissance américaine
ça déstabilise évidemment les attentats
du 11 septembre 2001 mais au final 1
al-qaïda a été chassé d'afghanistan
n'est plus en mesure pour l'instant
depuis de nombreuses années maintenant
de planifier des opérations d'envergure
contre les états unis ou contre des
alliés occidentaux
des états unis et on peut dire même que
dans la nébuleuse des organisations
terroristes inspirés par l'islam radical
al qaïda
aujourd'hui et peut-être pas là la
franchise la plus haute elle a été
remplacée notamment depuis 2014 par ce
fameux état islamique c'est peut-être
notre sujet on y reviendra parce que
parce que même dans le conflit actuel
l'état islamique ou une filiale de
l'état islamique qui vient être un
joueur dans le conflit actuel conclut
aujourd'hui l'on reviendra ce1
suite aux attentats du 11 septembre les
américains de barclays avec comme
objectif
tuer ben laden puis
c'est le revoir des talibans au début
c'était ça aussi c'était l'objectif
était également celui là mais
l'objectif il devenait consubstantielle
à celui de démanteler al-qaïda de tuer
ben laden et vous pouviez pas faire
remplir cet objectif là sans vous
débarrasser les talibans encore une fois
parce que les deux étaient tellement
imbriquées et
les talibans voilà n'avait pas d'autre
choix que d'appuyer al qaïda est ce qu
avait même été dit dans les semaines
suivant les attentats du 11 septembre
c'est que 1 l'administration américaine
du président w bush avait essayé ou
avait envoyé le signal aux talibans en
leur disant mais écoutez si vous me
livrer ben laden on viendra pas vous
chasser bon évidemment ça s'est pas fait
mais l'objectif initial est vraiment
celui là et cela étant
cet objectif de
le premier volet
attraper et neutraliser ben laden ça va
prendre du temps
pour l'interview le 7 octobre le début
de l'opération liberté immuable enduring
freedom c'est le 7 octobre 2001
ben laden il est neutralisé il est
éliminé tout début mai 2011 ironie de
l'histoire jacques tord le voilà dix ans
plus tard et il est même pas éliminé en
afghanistan il est éliminé au pakistan
voisin
dans la ville d'abbottabad qui abrite
notamment une école de formation des
officiers pakistanais pour là aussi
souligné le rôle avec le pakistan a là
dedans c'est pas d'ailleurs au pakistan
que les talibans c'est fort mais quelle
est cette formation-là celle ci fait
alors il ya les fameuses madrasa les les
écoles coraniques
au sein desquels finalement le mouvement
de talibans c'est en très grande partie
formé qui sont oui au pakistan il ya
d'autres il ya deux autre élément
intéressant lorsqu'on évoque le rôle du
pakistan l'as d'or mais de façon à
simplifier le premier élément c'est que
la frontière entre les deux pays elle
est pour eux enfin elle répond pas à des
réalités culturelles sociales ethniques
très très clair c'est ce qu'on appelle
la fameuse et ligne du rhin qui fait la
frontière au sud est entre l'afghanistan
et le pakistan elle a été
dessiner cette frontière cette
vigneronne par les britanniques qui au
19e siècle avait aussi essayé de
stabiliser l'afghanistan un sens sans
grand succès mais dans toute leur
perfidie et les britanniques s'étaient
dit on va séparer des communautés
notamment les pachtouns en deux et se
retourne et finalement contre les alliés
des britanniques les états unis au début
du 21e siècle parce que cette absence
enfin où cette frontière très poreuse
a permis aux talibans une fois qu'ils
ont été chassés du pouvoir
en décembre 2001 de trouver des refuges
au pakistan donc ça c'est le premier
élément il y à un pakistan une assise et
ni forte pour accueillir les talibans
lorsqu'ils ont cherché une refuse
l'autre élément important c'est le jeu
des services secrets pakistanais le
fameux intelligence
intelligence service y est si qui
s'en refaire toute la
période de l opposition à la présence
soviétique
c'est les services pakistanais si vous
voulez qui gérait ses fameux
moudjahidine dont les combattants la
liberté dont sont issus une partie des
talibans
et qui ont ensuite décidé de conserver
une alliance très forte avec les
talibans pour les financer pour les
accueillir sur leur territoire sans le
sang est chassé pour les armées pourquoi
les pakistanais font ça ils font ça
essentiellement pour utiliser les
talibans comme un facteur de stabilité
dans leur arrière-cour qu'est
l'afghanistan parce qu'ils les
pakistanais sont terrorisés par une
petite chose c'est la rivalité avec
l'inde et cette rivalité entre l'inde et
le pakistan explique en partie pourquoi
même si les pakistanais sont des alliés
des etats-unis dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme depuis le 11 septembre les
meilleurs c'est des alliés patrick au
mode et ils n'ont pas contribué à
stabiliser l'afghanistan est aujourd'hui
sont très contents de voir les talibans
reviennent au pouvoir parce que ce sont
des alliés alors que le régime que les
américains c'est entre autres les
occidentaux essayer de mettre en place à
kaboul
avait plutôt les faveurs de l'inde et
face à salé pakistanais avaient
l'impression d'être pris en étau entre
l'inde évidemment je l'est et au nord
ouest
l'afghanistan voilà appuyé par par les
occidentaux
donc si on se retourne au lendemain du
11 septembre les américains
d'avoir en afghanistan puis je crois que
la transition ou du moins la victoire
contre les régimes telle ba s'est fait
assez rapidement
oui ça prend quelques semaines 1 donc on
disait ça commence 7 octobre
au mois de décembre les talibans ont été
chassés de la plupart des grandes villes
et je pense même qu'ils perdent kaboul
dès le mois de décembre 2000 un lycée
allemand ce n'est que les américains
alors initialement mais ne se sont que
des forces spéciales américaines il ya
eu des images célèbres et je pense qu'il
ya des films grand public qu'il aura la
tasse est bien un des opérateurs de
forces spéciales et quelques agents de
la cia qui vont en afghanistan à dos de
cheval ou dan avec des valises pleines
d'armes et surtout de billets verts qui
est la meilleure arme dans la région
pour acheter les alliances et qui
viennent appuyer donc ses troupes ou
s'efforcent de l'alliance du nord - du
commandant massoud qui est mort quelques
parents et
qui vont bénéficier ses troupes au sol
de l'appui de la force aérienne
américaine ce qui va jouer un rôle clé
pour chasser les talibans alors il ya
les britanniques aussi initialement qui
vont qui vont aider qui vont aider
les américains et on s'aperçoit très
vite fin 2001 2002 de deux choses la
première c'est que chasser les talibans
c'est bien qu'est ce qu'on met après
voilà et on ne peut pas dire qu'on les a
chassés on repart à la maison surtout
qu'on n'a pas attrapé belnades donc on
en restait là donc face à ce premier
constat on dit mais il faut faire
quelque chose il faut stabiliser
l'afghanistan
le deuxième constat qui ressort très
rapidement
c'est notamment aux scènes des alliés
occidentaux des états unis de dire et
vous c'est et vous allez peut-être se
souvient peut-être aux auditeurs s'en
souviennent pas mais après le 11
septembre 2001
l'organisation du traité de l'atlantique
nord la fameuse autant qui est la
principale alliance de sécurité la
démocratie occidentale a évoqué son
fameux article 5 qui prévoit qu'une
attaque contre un pays et une attaque
contre l'alliance donc qui crée cette
solidarité
avant le 11 septembre 2001 cet article 5
n'a jamais été activé n'a jamais été
évoqué et là les autres pays qui sont
aussi terrifié par ce qui s'est passé à
new york washington et en pennsylvanie
que les américains par solidarité ont ce
réflexe de dire on veut agir à vos côtés
en vertu de l'article 5 de la charte de
l'otan sauf que l'administration de
george w bush qui assainit
unilatéraliste quand même d'agir tout
seul fait non non on n'a pas besoin de
votre aide parce que bon dans les
précédents de missions militaires
notamment au kosovo en 1999 ça marchait
pas bien notamment les européens vous
êtes trop lent de tergiverser mais de
définir les cibles on y va tout seul on
est capable de le faire et c'est le
secrétaire à la défense de george w bush
donald rumsfeld idée tenait mordicus
sauf que les semaines passent et
politiquement les alliés des etats unis
se disent ouais on a envie d'intervenir
on a envie de vous aider et l'otan cas
quand même été créée en 1949 pour faire
face à l'union soviétique depuis la
chute de l'union soviétique au début des
années 90 elle se cherche une raison de
les relever
voilà un vieux prêtre est exactement ici
à la lutte contre le terrorisme
ah c'est une chose 70's fait plus
vraiment d'accord mais on peut pas être
contre contre ça sur toile en septembre
donc voilà on va intervenir
à vos côtés ce que washington fini par
accepter en se disant grosso modo
nous on va se garder la chose contre le
terrorisme
et au maintien de l'opération khanjar
winfried l'otan
on accepte que vous veniez mais vous
allez faire la mission de stabilisation
ce que nous les américains n'aiment pas
faire et d'ailleurs en novembre 2000
lorsque bush fait campagne pour être élu
à la présidence en matière de politique
étrangère a dit nous on fera plus de
nation building ces opérations devraient
compliquer nos forces armées ça sert pas
à ça mais bon si les européens veulent
en faire après en afghanistan et les
canadiens amusez-vous à par exemple et
enfin bref exactement et ils
sous-traitent si je puis dire aux alliés
américains au sein de l'otan cette tâche
or les américains voient ils participent
un peu mais ils vont se garder
l'opération enduring freedom qui va
vivre aux côtés de l'opération de l'otan
isaf
donc qu'ils aient la force
internationale d'assistance de sécurité
ou un truc comme ça qui est mandatée par
le conseil de sécurité de l'onu pour
venir stabiliser le territoire afghan
après après la chute des talibans ces
deux missions elles vont coexister
des fois être plus ou moins de friture
sur la ligne et c'est l'un des facteurs
il y en a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup qui
explique aussi pourquoi au bout de vingt
ans de présence on a échoué comment
comment que l'armée américaine ou que ou
occidental en général est perçu au sein
de la population à regarder ce que est
ce que une ingérence américaine sait si
c'est bien vu du point de vue du citoyen
cette période là durant sa période
l'homme étendu mais loué au initialement
c'est pas accueilli avec beaucoup de
réticences parce que bon on l'évoqué
tout à l'heure le régime des talibans
n'étaient pas pas la vie la plus
sympathique un soussou les talibans donc
il ya un sentiment de libération
sauf que
l'administration w bush même son
souviens que c'était un président qui
n'avait pas une grande culture dire ça
comme ça
était préoccupé par une chose et avaient
cette lecture que l'afghanistan était le
tombeau des empires
et il s'est dit ils sont dix à
washington pour pas reproduire ça on va
pas envoyer une force d'occupation une
force qui pourrait être perçu comme une
armée d'invasion parce que manifestement
les afghans même pas ça vous allez me
dire il n'y a pas grand monde qui aime
avoir une armée car envahi son pays en
général donc c'est pour ça qu'ils vont
adopter
est en fait pour la plus grande partie
des vingt ans une stratégie dite de l'
empreinte légère le maximum de soldats
américains que vous allez avoir un avis
à nice temps c'est au tout début ou
tournant des années 2000 2010 entre 2009
et 2011 si vous voulez vous aller avoir
cent dix mille soldats américains pour
un total de 150 milles à peu près
soldats sont inclues toutes les forces
de l'otan les soviétiques pendant leurs
occupations la de 79 à 89 avait évalué
que pour stabiliser l'afghanistan
il fallait un million de soldats
alors les soldats américains ils sont
ils n'ont pas été perçues nécessairement
comme comme comme des envahisseurs par
la population ils ont essayé de limiter
le plus possible l'émergence de cette
perception là ils sont ils sont
peut-être pas totalement parvenu parce
que b il ya eu des bavures il faut pas
oublier je pense qu'en 20 ans vous avez
quand même 50 mille afghans qui sont
morts dont certains sont morts du fait
de bombardements américains où on
pensait par exemple ciblé un groupe
terroriste alors que c'était une famille
qui était en train de célébrer un
mariage avec des kalachnikov des civils
le final voilà mais des civils ont été
tués au total entre civils et forces de
sécurité afghanes en même temps vous
avez à peu près cent trente mille
personnes qui sont mortes et de 2001 à
aujourd'hui
à peu près et en contrepartie ces 2500
soldats américains qui sont morts en
afghanistan sur cette période là mais
donc ils ont quand même essayé de
limiter les risques sans succès absolu
évidemment avec des opérations unitaires
ya toujours ces dommages collatéraux
cette affreuse expression et surtout les
talibans ont réussi petit à petit à
partir du moment où ils ont pu trouver
refuge au pakistan remobilisés ils ont
réussi à entretenir cette idée qui
manifestement a un écho au sein de la
population afghane
que ce sont les seuls qui peuvent
résister à une invasion étrangère du
territoire afghan il ce qui explique un
peu
j'aurais tendance à dire même en bonne
partie leur facilité à reprendre le
pouvoir au cours des dernières semaines
c'est qu'ils touchent à quelque chose
d'assez présent aux scènes d'identité
nationale d'une bonne partie de la
population a fui la population notamment
les talibans oui oui clairement oui oui
oui alors évidemment les scènes qu'on
voit là depuis la mi-août à kaboul
d'afghans désespéré qui veulent partir
c'est légitime parce que encore une fois
il ya le souvenir des années
quatre-vingt seize à demi heure
j'ai à peu près 40% d'afghans depuis une
dizaine d'années qui aspirent à quitter
le pays alors et ça c'est quasiment
stable depuis une quarantaine d'années
et
lorsqu'ils voient arriver les talibans
ces gens là veulent naturellement partir
mais ils sont sont peut-être pas
majoritaire non plus et s'il n'y avait
pas ce soutien
au moins tacite au moins de principe de
la population à l'endroit des talibans
il y aurait eu des combats
on a vu que quelqu'un vendait entre rock
band en ville oui sentir et on est en
crise et presque à bras ouverts est ce
qu'on peut dire que
la présence if que au début ça a été une
victoire c'est rapide finalement puisque
la présence
longue des américains ont un peu
finalement été
la chose qui risque et qui a mené la
renaissance de ce mouvement le des
talibans qui comme devenu un prétexte
pour revenir est ce que le fait qu'il
était le conflit s'éternise c'est pas ce
que fait finalement que
qu'on ait reconnu finalement revenu à la
case départ
il ya plusieurs éléments à
premiers éléments je vous dirais qu'il
est important c'est le fait que lorsque
les talibans ont été chassés du pouvoir
à kaboul
ils n'ont pas été tous éliminés ils ont
encore une fois trouvé refuge au
pakistan et le les autorités à islamabad
on les voit qui tout à l'heure n'ont pas
décidé de chasser les talibans de les
enfermer
de lutter contre eux au contraire ils
ont dit
rejet les rayons vous restez vous êtes
tranquilles on va pas vous embêter parce
que aussi au pakistan ont la peur d'un
mouvement de talibans pakistanais on les
utilise dans le jeu géopolitique avec
l'inde mais il ya aussi des questions de
sécurité heure assez
évident donc ça c'est le premier élément
ils ont pu trouver refuge deuxième
élément important à mon sens c'est que
le fait qu'elle et les américains en
fait on jamais été capable pour
stabiliser le pays d'élaborer une
stratégie à long terme en fait on a
coutume de dire que les américains ont
pas mené une guerre de 20 en afghanistan
ils ont monté ils ont mené 20 fois une
guerre d'un an puisque à peu près tous
les ans vous avez un changement de
général en charge des forces armées sur
le terrain et qui arrive avec sa
nouvelle entre guillemets
stratégie sauf que pour stabiliser un
pays mené une opération dite de contre
insurrection
il faut s'inscrire dans la durée
il faut avoir énormément de moyenne
humain que ce soit civil ou militaire et
financier les moyens financiers les
américaines et les ont mis la guerre a
coûté à peu près de 1000 milliards de
dollars les moyens humains je vous
disais tout à l'heure au maximum 110
mille cent cinquante mille soldats 2000
milliards
laisser le temps à ce chef lieu
d'apparaître dans bretagne pour réaliser
l'immensité modeste
c'est colossal s'explique aussi pourquoi
aujourd'hui les américains soient assez
favorable au départ il trouve que ça
coûtait trop cher
donc on n'a pas été capable d'avoir une
stratégie
complète de contre insurrection et de
et de stabilisation
les américains en premier
donc le refuge des désagréments et le
troisième élément qui est quand même
aussi
important et qui explique l'échec ça a
été l'incapacité des dirigeants afghans
successifs qui sont arrivés avec les
valises des occidentaux à
acquérir une certaine légitimité aux
yeux de la population
ils sont perçus ces dirigeants là depuis
2004 essentiellement comme soit des
marionnettes des occidentaux dans le
pire des cas au mieux comme corrompu et
inefficace
la corruption est rampante c'est quelque
chose qui accompagne toujours ou quasi
systématiquement les interventions
d'envergure occidentales lorsque vous
arrivez dans un pays aussi pauvre
qu'elle avait gagné ce temps en demi
heure avec des milliers des millions des
milliards de dollars c'est sûr que ça
crée des problèmes en plus il dans vos
bagages vous avez des afghans mais
qu'ont vécu à l'étranger est bon qu'ils
sont complètement déconnectés des
réalités locales n'ont pas de réseaux
locaux qui viennent en place et il
dernier problème ça a été cette croyance
que vous pouviez créer un afghanistan
un régime centralisée
avec kaboul comme capitale qui contrôle
l'ensemble du territoire c'est contraire
à l'histoire du pays c'est antinomique
avec la géographie du pays
c'est la montagne et le désert
l'afghanistan regardez des cartes et
vous verrez la géographie explique en
partie en bonne partie pourquoi ce pays
est ingouvernable
d'un point de vue d' état centralisé que
c'est comme si vous aviez les alpes
voilà où alors là c'était une partie de
l'himalaya mais qui occupe l'ensemble de
votre territoire avec des vallées
difficilement accessible
et croire donc on pouvait avoir un
gouvernement centralisé depuis kaboul
donc c'est contraire à l'histoire c'est
contraire à la géographie et ses
contraires aussi à la culture politique
afghane
qui
préconise ou qui valorise
les approches locales on parle beaucoup
de gestion clanique
vallée par vale et les négociations les
délibérations très très longue
les occidentaux ont réussi sa
initialement en 2002
lorsque sous l'égide des nations unies
l'ancien diplomate algérien lakhdar
brahimi est arrivé en afghanistan a
convoqué une assemblée traditionnelle
afghane dont j'oublie le nom
mais dans laquelle après de longues
discussions a quand même émergé un
certain consensus politique ça a été
assez rapidement oublier cette
expérience en faveur dès 2004 d'une
constitution qui un peu à l'américaine
prévoyez un pouvoir centralisé fort avec
un président afghan auquel étaient
attribués beaucoup de pouvoir et ça
c'était assez mal perçu et ce qui
faisait qu'en fait le gouvernement ce
qu'on appelait le gouvernement afghan
2004 au vendredi 13 août du nil 21 ans
n'était en fait que le gouvernement de
kaboul il n'avait pas d'autorité au delà
york
puis la perception
occidentale de cette présence en
afghanistan leur de 3par mais est-ce que
la perception change après
2011 15
enfin malgré des démentis pis que la
raison principale crainte est
initialement pourquoi les américains
pourquoi les soldats mouraient en
afghanistan t-il à l'espèce de vision
ultra patriotique américaine de dire nos
soldats et nos nos enfants morts là bas
est ce que ça change la perception
international de la présence américaine
après 2011 après après le demande le
démantèlement de al qaïda ouais 2011
c'est vraiment la date charnière
parce que justement enfin ben laden
éliminé
début mai sur le double 3 mais je pense
quand même plus exactement
il ya aussi au delà de cet événement
majeur m qui symbolise le fameux mission
accomplished ouais ok là
le boss de la finlande en sont friands
les américaines reviennent presque
mais il ya aussi la fatigue de la guerre
qui commence à se faire sentir en 2011
il ya dix ans qu'elle les etats unis
sont en guerre en afghanistan est encore
plus
en irak même si en 2011 la guerre en
irak au mois d'août touche touche à sa
femme et à partir de ce moment là
dans les pays occidentaux on dira que
l'opinion publique américaine est celle
qui façonnent le plus les choses parce
que encore une fois c'est les
américaines coin plus de soldats alors
il y avait des canadiens y avait des
français il y avait des bulgares des
polonais des britanniques mais en nombre
beaucoup plus restreint
ils ont subi aussi un petit peu moins un
petit peu moins de perte même si le
canada a perdu 158 soldats quand même en
afghanistan c'est le troisième plus haut
total
après les américaines et elie
britannique mais à partir de 2011 la
population américaine donc
essentiellement
autour de 60% commence à dire bah
écoutez
on a fini finalement on n'a plus de
raison d'être il faudrait songer à se
retirer d'ici en inde voilà il ya très
très très très peu d'américains moins de
10% qui disent il faudrait rester 5 10
ou plus d'années pour stabiliser leur
est stabilisé je vois mal le choix malin
avec under forrest et le stabiliser le
gouvernement pour d un pays au sein
duquel vous avez duquel les intérêts
nationaux américains ne sont pas
évidents au lendemain du 11 septembre
2001 c'est clair pourquoi vous allez en
afghanistan et la population est
absolument d'accord les taux
d'approbation de w bush après le 11
septembre 2001 l'ont très bien démontré
au-delà de 90% cette guerre elle était
perçue comme nécessaire à partir du
moment où vous avez éliminé le méchant
les américaines pourquoi on en reste là
ce cas là c'est intéressant c'est que ce
sentiment qu'on a plus rien à faire là
il se traduit pas politiquement par une
énorme opposition à la présence
américaine là bas en fait ça se traduit
plus par un désintérêt progressif à tel
point que les médias n'en parlent
quasiment plus moi ce qui m'avait frappé
si vous voulez par exemple lors de la
campagne électorale de 2016
le sujet de l'afghanistan n'a jamais été
abordé dans les ventres donald trump et
hillary clinton la campagne
présidentielle de 2020 le sujet dans mon
souvenir s'il a été abordée ça a été
vraiment en note de bas de page très
très rapidement alors même que en
février 2020 trump était arrivé à un
accord avec les talibans
qui prévoyait le retrait dans les
conséquences se feront sentir en ce
moment et on aurait pu imaginer que
l'accord négocié par trump qui était
vraiment pas bon parce qu'ils savaient
pas négocier des accords contrairement à
ce qu'il disait
soit un sujet politique ça n'a même pas
été dans la campagne de 2020 donc il y
avait un désintérêt complet jusqu'à
il y a quelques semaines où la
population américaine là comment ça
serait intéressé évidemment parce qu'on
en parle beaucoup ce qui se passe en
afghanistan ce qui est assez intéressant
à cet égard là c'est que
elle maintient dans une très large
majorité cette population américaine son
désir de quitter l'afghanistan
par contre elle est critiquée elle peut
l'être évidemment sur la façon dont le
désengagement ou le retrait et le
retrait se fait et ce qui vaut pour la
population américaine voit assez
largement dans les autres pays où il ya
eu
même pas un ressentiment par rapport à
l'afghanistan
désintérêt complet ce qui est très
différente par rapport à ce qui s'était
passé au vietnam dans les années 70 il
avait des grandes manifestations
contre la présence américaine
c'est intéressant on était de commencer
ces faits justement ce retrait là parce
que l'étude il ya eu un accord donc il
ya eu discussion entre les gouvernements
américain et les talibans sont venus à
un accord dont on va s'en aller
at-elle telles conditions finalement
c'était quoi ces conditions le ps que ça
a été respectée ou venant alors ce qui
est déjà très intéressant c'est que les
américains considèrent les talibans
comme une entité terroriste commence par
les soldats canadiens aussi sauf que les
américains ont quand même compris à la
fin des années 2000 est notamment sous
l'administration obama
que même si on n'aime pas les talibans
on l'avait pas pouvoir y faire
disparaître d'afghanes ils représentent
une force politique donc même si obama
l'a commencé à négocier avec les
talibans de façon plus ou moins directe
notamment par l'entremise du qatar
étaient encore au qatar que l'essentiel
des discussions ont lieu avec les
talibans et autres hommes qui n'aimaient
pas les guerres il a souvent dit que
c'était une perte d'argent et lui
voulaient se désengager de tous
d'afghanistan en premier lieu il avait
voulu se désengager de syrie après la
défaite ou après les états unis et
vaincu les l'état islamique et est donc
30 continue ses négociations avec les
talibans et
là il ya peut-être deux problèmes dans
cet accord qui a été noué le premier
essai les conditions qui sont pas très
très contraignantes pour le retrait
c'est à dire que les talibans a priori
uniquement à s'engager à
faire en sorte que l'afghanistan ne
redevienne pas un territoire à partir
duquel ou sur lequel puisse établir une
organisation terroriste qui planifiait
des attentats contre les états unis ou
des alliés des etats unis donc les
talibans ont eu juste à dire
d'accord on a pu être des méchants on va
plus acquérir al-qaïda version
3.0 est ce que l'objectif principal des
états unis avant de stabiliser un pays
c'est s'assurer qu'il peut d'autres
attentats sur le territoire
et dans ce cas là c'était très clair et
byden comme trump tant que les talibans
respecte cet engagement devrait pas
poser
trop de soucis l'autre
engagement des talibans
c'était qu'ils participent à une
discussion politique avec le pouvoir en
place à kaboul pour essayer de de créer
si vous voulez un paysage politique plus
ou moins unifié plus ou moins stabilisé
grosso modo on leur demandait de ne pas
renverser le pouvoir en place m trop
rapidement il ya n'ont pas tout à fait
tout à fait respecté leur parole alors
il y avait un autre province second
souci avec cet accord là où de
l'a22 contrainte qui se battent très
contraignantes ou d'engagements dont
le respect va être dur à mesurer
concrètement le donc l'autre problème
c'est que les américains en négociant
avec les talibans ont complètement mis
de côté le gouvernement afghan
ils ont carrément imposé au gouvernement
négociations avec les talibans déjà je
vous disais tout à l'heure que l'un des
problèmes de ce gouvernement c'était son
manque de légitimité et en plus vous le
mettez pas dans la négociation avec
l'une des principales forces politiques
du pays la population va pas vraiment il
est pertinent et les talibans mais
encore montreuil qui est pertinent
puisque même les alliés de ce
gouvernement là les américaines ne font
pas participé soit autour de la table
voilà il ne les inquiète même pas autour
de la table ça ça a été l'un des
problèmes en contrepartie les talibans
exiger
un retrait total des troupes américaines
l'accord négocié par trompe aurait pu
essayer d'imposer une présence
résiduelle
comme il y en avait jusque là encore
quelques semaines de 2500 à 3000
peut-être cinq mille soldats américains
qui resteraient en afghanistan pour à
s'assurer que les talibans ne soit pas
trop trop méchant mais surtout pour
regarder des yeux sur place et éviter
une nouvelle organisation terroriste
arrive en afghanistan avec comme
objectif 15 jours d'attaquer les
etats-unis les talibans voulaient
absolument pas
et initialement dont vous avez exigé que
le retrait américain soit achevé début
mai 2021 joe biden qu à l arrivée à la
maison blanche il n'y a pas de déchirer
totalement l'accord de février 2020 il a
dit je respecte l'esprit de l'accord
sauf que le retrait des troupes on va le
faire d'ici le 11 septembre 2021 et il a
même fixé la date du 31 août
2000 21 qui d'après les derniers
développements
et ce qui a été dit hier par le
président joe biden
est coulé dans le béton donc puisqu'il a
encore réitéré
sa volonté d'avoir fini les opérations
d'évacuation et retirer les troupes
américaines d'ici le 31 août 2021
donc pour lui que pour lesquels talibans
prennent contrôle de kaboul ça change
rien son plein c'est on
inquiète les pays peu importe exactement
donc on peut même on peut même supposer
qu'ils
parce que j'imagine que c'était aussi
celle après avoir que ce que les
talibans allaient reprendre possession
de ce pays à bayonne a été très clair
voire même durée on pourrait dire
cynique dans la première conférence de
presse qu'il a fait après la chute de
kaboul
je sais plus ça doit être le 17 décembre
le 17 août pardon ou le 18 août dernier
il a dit très clairement
si al qaïda avait été au lit et mène en
2001 on serait pas intervenu en
afghanistan pour chasser les talibans
donc il serait au pouvoir encore
aujourd'hui sera encore là voilà
peut-être il aurait été renversé mais
enfin ah oui il y aurait une guerre
civile mais
pour joe biden s'est pas pressé pas un
problème le fait que les talibans ou
là-bas alors évidemment ça va créer un
débat aux états uniens et peut-être pas
qu aux etats unis alors est ce que les
idées américaines ne devrait pas rester
pour essayer de stabiliser au nom des
valeurs notamment occidentales quand on
regarde la menace qui aujourd'hui va
peser sur les femmes notamment en
afghanistan dans les prochaines semaines
les prochains mois est ce que ce n'est
pas la responsabilité morale des etats
unis nous occidentaux de lutter en
faveur de la veuve et l'orphelin si je
puis dire il y en a qui vont dire oui
c'est de la responsabilité morale
notamment les internationalistes
libéraux comme les appelle en relations
internationales puis on a d'autres des
réalistes peu plus cyniques en herbe
écoute et non
les intérêts des états unis en
afghanistan ne sont pas vitaux ils ont
été remplis à partir du moment où on a
démantelé al-qaïda et on a tué ben laden
rappelons que ben laden encore une fois
y'a pas été tués en afghanistan mais au
pakistan voisin et
ils vont dire
c'est réaliste et baden s'inscrit là
dedans
vallières c'est pas notre guerre
c'est la guerre des afghans voilà et il
l'a dit très clairement il a dit
le fait que le président afghan
plie bagage de jouable donc le vendredi
13 le fait que les forces armées
afghanes ne combattent pas ne font que
confirmer ce qu'ils lisent ça la
nécessité pour nous de partir
parce que c'est pas notre guerre
sous-entendu on n'a pas d'intérêt là et
surtout on a d'autres enjeux beaucoup
plus important et cette guerre-là à la
mobiliser des ressources à la coûter
excessivement cher à la monopolisé notre
attention alors qu'il ya des enjeux bien
plus important sur la scène
internationale auxquelles sont
confrontés les états unis et il ya aussi
des défis bien plus important sur la
scène politique intérieure unis auquel
mois président biden je dois ma tach et
donc qu'elle en quelque sorte on
al'impression byden c'est un peu comme
un docteur qui arrivait à la conclusion
que voilà le traitement la palliatifs il
fonctionnait plus il fallait des
branchés ou arracher le sparadrap c'est
violent c'est pas joli mais tant pis il
fallait le faire pour tourner la page
parce que
dans son esprit il a jamais été très
favorable en chine building maiden
surtout en afghanistan
dans son esprit fallait tourner la page
il fallait accepter cette défaite
pour les américains si on
définissait la victoire comme la
création d'un organisme instable il
ressemblerait à la suisse par exemple
puis en ce moment là on est à quelques
jours de la date butoir donnée par le
président américain
puis le sait la logistique a essayé de
sortir tout le monde de l'au delà les
scènes qu'on voit les photos qu'on voit
tout le monde aéroports qui essaient de
de fonctionner comme ils peuvent
quel est le niveau de coopération des
talibans dans l'exercice de sortir les
américains et leurs alliées
d'afghanistan
parce que de la conversation qu'on
impute en taule
si je me mets dans la peau des talibans
je me dis on va les aider à s'en aller
faites juste partir quitter laissez nous
laisser nous le pays comme comme on le
leur à fait juste footfoot et le cam
ouais alors c'est un calcul délicat que
doivent faire les talibans parce que à
la rigueur il pourrait se dire oui tout
ce qu'ils nous aiment pas tous
nos frères afghans qui ne nous aiment
pas les parts est comme ça bon débarras
sauf que il se prive aussi de forces
vives
pour faire fonctionner le pays le seul
capital finalement la seule richesse de
l'afghanistan au-delà de toute la
mythologie autour de la richesse minière
et blabla c'est quand même sa population
et la ceux qui partent
oui ce sont des gens qui ont collaboré
avec
les occupants étrangers mais ce sont des
gens aussi quand
on est à l'encontre des compétences dont
pourraient avoir besoin les talibans
pour gouverner en fait les talibans ceux
qui ont travaillé avec les américains a
essayé d'établir un gouvernement stable
ils ont fait en 10 mai forme et le son
sont très très apte à capable de garder
un pays de faire rouler un pays n'en
font exactement exactement et ça se
mange le veulent partir ils veulent
partir parce qu'ils ont peur d'être
identifiés par les talibans comme des
traîtres et de subir les conséquences et
quart monde d'être tué
donc
tout à fait légitime un qu'ils aient
peur mais les talibans
ils ont accompli le plus simple pour
l'instant c'est à dire reprendre le
pouvoir le plus difficile arrive ça être
exercé le pouvoir ah et sinon aucun
personnel compétent s'ils font peur si
vous voulez à tout le monde s'ils n'ont
pas un minimum de respectabilité pays
vont se retrouver eux aussi
face à une population qui va
s'apercevoir qu'ils sont peut-être pas
compétent qu'il ne qui ne fournissent
pas des biens publics essentiels
l'électricité l'eau la sécurité et du
coup ça risque d'ouvrir un espace
politique à des mouvements d'opposition
il y en a déjà un dans la vallée du
panjshir
l'ancien vice-président larguant lui a
retraité dans la vallée du panjshir il
n'a pas pris l'avion pour quitter le
pays comme le président mais il a promis
d'organiser une résistance
les talibans - essai de la combattre
dans un premier temps mais il peut y
avoir des poches de résistance dans le
pays et il est pas tout à fait exclu que
dans les prochains mois peut-être
prochaines années vous ayez une nouvelle
guerre civile
en afghanistan donc les talibans on
constate que voilà il ils essaient de de
retenir peut-être un peu des gens chez
eux ou ne pas les inciter 3 partir mais
ne pas non plus
apparaître comme trop brutaux dans la
volonté de les retenir a alors bon il ya
des épisodes où ils ont tiré sur la
foule ou d'essayer de d'empêcher des
gens ne se rendent à l'aéroport c'est
évident mais il avait aussi de leur
crédibilité ils ont un équilibre
à trouver puis on a vu aujourd'hui on
est le 27 août aujourd'hui
26 ils sont confrontés les talibans à
l'un des risques qu'on voyait poindre
depuis quelques jours à l'aéroport c'est
celui d'un attentat puisqu'il en attente
a aujourd'hui enfin en fin de journée à
kaboul
à proximité de l'aéroport
alors au moment où on se parle je sais
pas qui a revendiqué l'attentât il y
avait des rumeurs que l'état islamique
qui est un peu présents en afghanistan
qui pas allié des talibans contrairement
à al qaïda pourrait être tenté de mener
c'est ce type d'attentât là ça à la
signature cet attentat de ce que fait
habituellement en état islamique
c'est-à-dire attaquer des cibles très
vulnérable et là des milliers de gens
qui attendent désespérément d'aller à
l'aéroport c'est vraiment des cibles
vulnérables donc c'est pas tout à fait
un petit creux sur eux et il va falloir
voir comment les talibans réagi ça ça
par contre il ya un truc sur lequel ils
sont très claires c'est qu'ils veulent
que tout cela se termine et ces
évacuations le 30ème
ils les taliban apparaissent dans une
situation somme toute assez précaire
parce que
ils doivent mettre de l'avant le fait
qu'
ils veulent faire ce dans l'ordre dans
le petit coup ils veulent reprendre le
reprend le pouvoir mais paul faire de
façon violente en guerre d'un côté il ya
la résistance qui se forme de l'autre
côté il ya ceux qui disent que qui sont
qui sont ramollis py qui sont plus assez
radicaux qui viennent former quand les
joies sur le tremplin
qui vient de se joindre à l'état
islamique puis qui pourrait éclairer les
talibans y compris en hand se faire dire
que son pull sont ramollis d'un côté de
l'autre côté qui a une force de
deux réponses qui est en train de se
former ce comme une drôle de situation
oui ça serait assez ironique qu'elle et
les talibans ne fasse doubler par là sur
leur droite par des extrêmes
et un jour on lui à dire finalement il
ya plus de sa musique elle est haï bahem
bizarre enfin c'est un peu bizarre
à envisager mais comme on disait tout à
l'heure leur vrai défi il est maintenant
gouverner et comment ils font pour
gouverner parce que leur première
expérience à l'ap a été couronnée d'un
succès extraordinaire alors là ils
essaient de grun fois montrer patte
blanche parce qu'ils aimeraient avoir
notamment une forme de respectabilité à
l'international pour faire en sorte de
pouvoir utiliser notamment l'argent
qu'ils avaient été données au précédent
gouvernement afghan par la communauté
internationale qui a été gelé les
américaines qu'elles allaient français
ce beau monde a bloqué les avoirs et les
talibans ne peuvent pas utiliser un
grande partie cet argent là alors ils
essayent d'avoir des soutiens ailleurs
c'est pour ça qu'on les a vus a
essayé de se nouer des contacts ou
montrer qu'il a des contacts
diplomatiques avec la chine être gentil
aussi avec la russie parce qu'ils disent
voilà un minimum
toléré
on va peut-être être assez respectable
pour qu'ils aient des relations et en
fait il faut de l'argent simplement pour
gérer un état de l'argent alors ils ont
pu se renflouer les caisses de
l'organisation
en cultivant l'opium
mais voilà alors à moins de devenir un
narco état
ce que pas tout à fait impossible non
plus n'ont dans leur cave c'est le plus
gros producteur d'opium finalement
l'afghanistan depuis un bon bout de
temps
les talibans vont essayer de trouver des
accords à droite et à gauche et alors là
ce qui va être intéressant aussi à
surveiller non seulement c'est comment
eux politiquement
ils vont jouer le jeu d'ailleurs on voit
avec les promesses qu'ils font à
l'endroit des femmes leur dernière
déclaration ils disent ils encouragent
les femmes et les jeunes filles à rester
à la maison pendant quelques temps le
temps qu'ils forment tous leurs
combattants à une bonne interaction avec
la gent féminine est grosso modo pour
votre sécurité attendait qu'on a
expliqué des séminaires de formation
voilà
attendait quand les former nos
combattants les plus échevelés sur la
façon de se comporter
évidemment ils vont appliquer la charia
et une vision encore une fois rigoriste
mais on veut quand même garder les
femmes dans l'espace public
sous certaines conditions non évidemment
on peut douter de cet engagement des
talibans encore une fois l'expérience
montre que c'est pas les gens les plus
ouverts mais donc ça être intéressant
des surhommes et ça va être intéressant
de voir aussi ce qu'est les occidentaux
ont fait par rapport à ça dans le sens
où on peut retirer les troupes les
américains bon ils sont manifestement
engagé à le faire donc ils doivent
retirer leurs forces armées mais ce
qu'il faudrait pas faire ça serait faire
l'erreur de retirer les diplomates
alors c'est pas facile comme décision de
laisser des diplomates qui par
définition sont pas les forces armées
dans un pays
qui est quand même assez tendu où la
situation sécuritaire et est difficile
mais ça serait la meilleure des choses à
faire
non seulement pour avoir de
l'information sur ce qui se passe pour
être directement sur le terrain mais
aussi pour montrer aux talibans mais
regardez vous voulez être respectable et
nous on va rester accepter les diplômés
accepter les diplomates vous êtes
responsable à des conditions de sécurité
parce que un pays qui accueillent des
diplomates c'est le gouvernement de ce
pays qui est en premier lieu responsable
de la sécurité des diplomates étrangers
sur son territoire
il a il faudrait vraiment que les
occidentaux disent belle voilà on est là
on a évacué le plus de monde possible
mais on va garder des représentations
une ambassade à kaboul on vous fait
confiance que vous voulez faire c'est
comme du monde fait qu'on voit là on
vous laisse la chance de le prouver
voilà alors c'est pas évident a fait un
diplomate américain puis rester en
afghanistan ce moment le
web mais si on veut continuer dans cette
pression justement ccpo 6-6-6 pop art
d'avoir des troupes sur place
c'est par le refus de signer des accords
avec ces gouvernements là par exemple si
mettons les droits humains de base sont
pas respectés par les talibans chez les
citoyens un moyen de pression ça serait
de dire bon on va pas de commercer avec
vous puis après ce si ce pays le gagnant
sera mort spithill et comme hôtel bas
retrouvent isolés comme sisyphe pas
d'argent pas de découvert non c est ce
qu est ce que c est ce que ces ceux où
est ce qu'on peut imaginer que justement
les
du thalbach vont se modérait finalement
peut-être l'occasion de la charia luz où
on espère que ça va ressembler à 87 à
2001 au niveau de la manière de
gouverner d'appliquer les lois et cela
mais
j'ai du mal à imaginer les talibans
totalement modérée même si depuis
quelques mois il démontre une certaine
habileté politique
encore une fois
ils ont un certain talent politique vous
reprenez pas le pouvoir comme ils l'ont
fait sans avoir à voile à ce minimum de
talent là qui leur permet d'avoir un
appui populaire
tout à l'heure ils n'ont pas repris le
territoire en se battant beaucoup il n'y
a pas eu des combats terribles donc ils
ont cette assise là et ils ont ce talent
là où je suis plus sceptique
à l'avenir c'est sur leur capacité à
garder une position homogène et unifiée
parce qu'il risque d'y avoir
au sein du mouvement taliban
à peut-être des factions qui vont pas
être d'accord certaines qui serait temps
ils sont présents du sco - plus
fondamentalistes religieux d'autres plus
que c'est le plus le pouvoir qui la
finalité non l'instauration de netto
donc ça peut créer des dissensions
assez rapidement
des puissances étrangères peuvent
alimenter ces dissensions là je veux
dire je vous disais tout à l'heure la
remet la plus importante dans beaucoup
de pays en afghanistan en particulier
c'est le billet vert
donc vous pouvez par des moyens comme ça
entretenir des dissensions au sein du
mouvement du mouvement de talibans
et évidemment ce goût
cette autorité là va être marquée de
sanctions je veux dire on voit bien les
politiques les décideurs politiques
occidentaux même s'ils ont pas encore
coordonner le type de sanction mais un
qui va l'appliquer et comment ils voient
les appliqués ils vont en imposer des
sanctions va pas commercer avec
l'afghanistan des talibans aussi
facilement qu'on commerce avec le japon
c'est bien évident en plus vous pouvez
me dire et pas grand-chose à commercer
avec l'afghanistan - qu'on légalise
l'opium et l'héroïne voilà alors on voit
que les chinois par exemple font
miroiter aux talibans
des accords de développement économique
qu'aux modo enfin comme ils font un peu
partout les chinois c'est vous nous
laisser exploiter vos ressources
naturelles en l'occurrence les
ressources minières et puis nous on
n'est pas très regardant sur votre mode
de gouvernance et on va vous donner de
l'argent voire construire des
infrastructures en plus les chinois ils
ont aussi une demande vis-à-vis des
talibans
ils ont une toute petite frontière avec
l'afghanistan
la chine et il aimerait bien que les
talibans n'abrite pas
mouvement qui pourrait appuyer la
minorité musulmane chinoise han et
femmes et ouïghours dont parle depuis
quelques années qui sont persécutés
comme il faut ou nettement persécutés
pendant en chine donc il ya cet intérêt
aussi de la part de la chine et les
talibans vont essayer d'aller chercher
un peu des appuis comme ça ils vont se
retrouver fatalement très très très très
isolée
ce qui n'est pas
non plus un gage absolu de faiblesse du
régime parce que si vous regardez dans
l'histoire les occidentaux ont essayé de
sanctionner d'isoler des pays fait des
régimes politiques sans que ceux ci ne
disparaissent
regardez l'iran voisin depuis 1979 les
américains essaient de voilà d'imposer
des sanctions est de faire tomber le
régime n'est pas tombé cuba là aussi
l'autre grand exemple de pays que les
américains ont voulu isoler le régime
castriste même s'il évolue il n'est pas
tombé à cause des sanctions américaines
la corée du nord spy donc les talibans
peuvent trouver un moyen de
de survivre j'évoquais la possibilité
d'être narco étant
pourquoi pas sinon est-ce que de ce
pétrole noc instant pas vraiment pas
vraiment l on parle plus de ces fameuses
terres rares l'un donc c'est ses
ressources minières qui sont d'autant
plus importantes avec dans la
fabrication des batteries au lithium-ion
notamment tiendront là de plus en plus
besoin notamment lorsqu'on parle
d'électrification sport il ya cette idée
que le taliban du helmand l'afghanistan
serez riche de ce type de terres rares
la ce a jamais été vraiment réellement
démontré surtout pour pouvoir exploiter
cette ressource là il faut que le pays
soit stable
voilà ce qui est paul
pourquoi est ce qu'il y avait
une espèce de croyance que les
américains utilisaient le prétexte du 11
septembre pour
aller chercher les ressources en
afghanistan pourquoi tu sais tu
t'appelles martienne aussi qu'on espère
c'est que ces jeunes bip c'est peut-être
plus référence à la guerre en irak mais
encore là juste possible un fondement se
met sans que quelqu'un était plus jeune
on attendait et les berges sango du
sabot pour les pétroles tournant de ce
jamais fouillé plus loin des lieux de
soins fond de vérité à ceux notés que
pour nous éclairer là dessus alors si
l'on est et un afghanistan pour les
ressources minières
ils ont pas été très bon puisque à
priori les contrats qui pourraient être
signés ils vont pas être donnée à des
entreprises américaines
jeudi en disant à l'instant que c'est
les chinois qui vont se prive donc
voilà c'était leur objectif premier ils
sont manifestement une capable de
l'atteindre on l'a beaucoup parlé de
cet appétit des états unis pour les
ressources naturelles des pays étrangers
lorsqu'on a une vision impérialiste ou
la politique étrangère américaine comme
étant une politique impérialiste et
c'est vrai que lorsqu'on a
débattu de la guerre en irak à partir de
2003 ça faisait partie chez les
critiquant l'intervention des arguments
principaux en disant on va en irak parce
qu'il ya du pétrole est juste peut-être
un peu pour revenir en arrière et faire
le lien entre l'afghanistan et l'irak
l'un des problèmes qui explique aussi
les difficultés des américains à
stabiliser l'afghanistan c'est qu'on a
détourné l'attention de l'afghanistan
très rapidement pour passer à l'irak
n'avait pas élaboré la stratégie sera
l'afghanistan en 2002 que déjà w bush et
surtout les conservateurs autour de w
bush voulait aller en irak et d'ailleurs
barack obama lorsqu'il s'est lancé en
politique et qu'il a fait campagne avant
d'être élu en 2008 disait qu'elle rompt
la guerre en afghanistan était
nécessaire et les chances de succès en
afghanistan avait été
affaibli parce que l'attention et les
ressources a été détourné sur l'irak
était une guerre de choix une guerre
inutile c'est quoi les motivations les
prétextes en irak alors voilà
podcast mais mettons c'est pas parce que
c'est vrai c'est vrai que ces deux gars
là même dans ma tête à moi sont
confondues pendant pendant des années ah
oui elle dans la guerre d et dans la
tête des américains au sida se sont
confondus parce qu'elles se soient
alimentés si vous voulez être le plus
bref possible je vous promets donc je
disais qu elle n ait problème c'est que
pour l'afghanistan c'est en les amis w
bush allaient rapidement désintéressé
pour passer à l'irak pourquoi ils se
sont intéressés à l'irak
w bush si vous voulez il ya trois
facteurs principaux
le premier il est de nature militaire
notamment le secrétaire à la défense de
l'époque donald rumsfeld
qui était un partisan de la
transformation des forces armées
américaines voulaient démontrer à la
face du monde que la supériorité
technologique des états unis leur
permettait d'avoir les forces armées qui
pouvait faire ce qu'elle voulait dans le
monde alors l'exemple afghan
il était satisfait mais c'était comme un
petit entraînement
allait jouer contre les pee wee si vous
voulez et là il s'est dit en irak
pendant les années 90 et avant la guerre
du golfe en 80 golfeurs en 90 91
lorsqu'il s'agit de chasser direct de
saddam hussein du koweït
on nous a présenté l'irak comme un pays
redoutable qui ne grande armée l'an 2000
on s'est dit ben en 2002 se dit pourquoi
pas aller à montrer quand les fortes
attentes sur les irakiens bon puncheur
bol de toute façon personne ne les a et
il fallait envoyer donc ce message à la
scène internationale un objet dur en
salle
au premier rang sera sa détention à
l'adversaire chinois
les démontrer cette supériorité
technologique des états unis à aux
rivaux des états unis donc l'irak
c'était un bon champ d'entraînement ça
c'est la première raison militaire ou
infirmation de la puissance militaire la
deuxième raison elle est
je vous dirais
idéologie
la troisième finale la deuxième raison
elle a trait à la sécurité c'est le
fameux argument à double argument du
lien entre al-qaïda et saddam hussein et
de la présence d'armé nucléaire
en irak il y avait un lien entre
saddam hussein et al qaïda alors voilà
ces deux arguments étaient bidons
pas d'armes nucléaires aucun lien voilà
c'était absolument faux
là il ya mensonge de l'administration 1
w bush s'est clairement établi surtout
sur le lien entre saddam hussein et al
qaïda au contraire c'est plutôt des
rivaux et évidemment sur les armes de
destruction massive c'est un mensonge
mais disons que moins problématique ou
moins - abject que le lien à al qaïda
saddam hussein dans la mesure où
l'information était un petit peu plus
flou il y avait un débat puis le régime
était tellement autoritaire de saddam
hussein qui avait même désir acquiert
dans l'appareil de sécurité irakiennes
qui pensaient qu'ils avaient des armes
nucléaires donc mais l'argument donc
c'était de voile à assurer la sécurité
des états unis en éliminant ces deux
menaces et le troisième argument
principal qui a présidé à la guerre en
irak c'est un argument de nature
idéologique qui était porté par ce
fameux mouvement là qu'a eu son heure de
gloire à cette époque là les
néoconservateurs qui grosso modo on dit
les attentats du 11 septembre 2001 ont
été provoqués par al qaïda parce que les
nôtres pays pendant trop longtemps à
appuyer des régimes autoritaires dans le
monde arabo musulman
ce qui est pas totalement idiot comme
argument d'un point de vue théorique ils
se sont dit on va aller en irak chasser
un régime autoritaire et implanter une
démocratie parce que les démocraties ça
se fait pas la guerre et tout le monde
aime vivre en démocratie donc les
irakiennes pourront pas voilà être des
alliées à des organisations terroristes
et ils sont ils sont dit on va aller
change on va faire vraiment du
changement de régime de l'ingénierie
politique et sociologique en dix ans
en un beau terrain de jeu irak c'est un
pays encore une fois avec un chef que
personne n'aime saddam hussein il ya une
population éduquée qui est formé et on
va commencer à transformer le moyen
orient en rentrant en irak a pris
voulait faire tache d'huile la syrie
liant et in fine et l'arabie saoudite
évidemment ça n'a pas marché il ya alors
et vous pourriez me dire il ya peut-être
une quatrième argument qui est le fameux
argument de pétrole parce qu'il ira qui
camus laine des pays avec le plus de
ressources pétrolières au monde et
facilement exploitable sur ce pétrolier
un peu comme un arabie saoudite sauf que
là j'ai tendance à croire l'argumentaire
de l'administration w bush qui en
février 2003 par l'intermédiaire du
sous-secrétaire à la défense paul
wolfowitz disait écoutait si on faisait
la guerre contre saddam hussein pour
avoir son pétrole le plus simple ça
serait de signer un accord avec saddam
hussein et exploiter son pétrole
sous-entendu ça nous a pas empêchés dans
le passé d'être alliés avec des régimes
autoritaires pour avoir accès à des
ressources comme moyen d'accès pétrole
que d'envoyer l'armée dans un pays voilà
et in fine et en plus ils n'ont même pas
eu le pétrole c'est des entreprises
russes un peu françaises et chinoises
comme pu l'exploiter ça a été ça a été
très compliqué
ça clarifie les choses pour moi que
moins est ce que est ce que l'idée que
par exemple qu'un jour on voit une
démocratie en afghanistan
sans ingérence étrangère si farfelue
souci quelque chose comme quand tu
commences à nine démocratie en fait
non mais
parce que si on passe de régimes
autoritaires un régime autoritaire qui
prend le pouvoir par la force je vois
pas comment un joueur une démocratie qui
s'est montré un peu alors
la question est excellente je la pose
est d'ailleurs un travail de session en
examen final à tous mes étudiants que je
vais avoir la session d'automne dans
tous les forfaits joueur va devoir de
protéger
l'image de ce qui s'est passé c'est pour
savoir si lui ou leurs preuves
vous allez suivre votre prof ça fait pas
de carte de la voie au jeu pas donné
toute la réponse comment ils vont tous
d'avoir 100% à l'examen sera pas
intéressant courrier
lorsqu'on regarde un petit peu pourquoi
anna l'échec de l'afghanistan est encore
échec parce qu'on n'a pas réussi à
construire un état stable et avec des
valeurs qui pourrait ressembler aux
valeurs libérales telles qu'on les
connaît en occident on s'aperçoit qu'on
n'a pas compris deux choses importantes
dans la culture afghane la première
chose c'est leur rapport à la justice
les américains ont dépensé il ya eu des
études qui ont été faites assez
intéressante sur sa pas loin d'un
milliard de dollars pour former des
juristes un peu sur le modèle qu'on
connaît notamment aux états unis a
amassé de la preuve les plaidoiries
multiples un parquet fait ça
et les afghans n'ont jamais eu confiance
dans ce système là parce qu'ils
comprennent pas nécessairement parce que
les fonctionnaires chargés d'appliquer
ce système là on était à vulnérable à de
la corruption
parce que ce système là
était trop long et encore une fois face
à ce manque de confiance en matière de
justice les talibans ont pu s'infiltrer
et dire nous on vous propose quelque
chose qui est très simple c'est la
charia
sa règle les différends du quotidien si
votre voisin vous appliquez votre chèvre
voilà qu'est ce qui va se passer et on
va le régler pas besoin d'aller au
tribunal
de remplir une plainte fin
notre vision occidentale de la justice
on a essayé de l'implanter en
afghanistan et de l'administration de la
justice on l'a voulu l'implanter en
afghanistan ça n'a pas fonctionné parce
qu'il ya culturellement sur place on
n'était pas ouvert à ça et l'autre
élément qui pose problème aussi ça a été
manifestement le notre vision des
rapports hommes femmes en afghanistan
c'est une société hyper conservatrice
hyper traditionalistes ce que nous on
estime normal nécessaire
les rapports rigaud hommes femmes la
liberté des femmes à s'habiller comme
elles veulent à faire ce qu'elles
veulent aller où ils veulent mais en
afghanistan on n'est pas rendu là
et ça ça a choqué
ça dérangeait pas mal d'afghans
notamment dans les régions rurales plus
traditionalistes ou on y voyait si vous
voulez une forme d'ingérence occidentale
se faire imposer des choses donc drilles
vingtaine d'années l'a finalement eu un
espèce de d'ouverture de de valeur plus
excitante avec son hub c'était paul est
un certain d'afghans qui voyait d'un bon
oeil non parce que ça elle était quand
même posé hors sol et l'afghan
l'afghanistan c'est un territoire très
aride au niveau de sa géographie mais au
niveau aussi de ses idées politiques
d'une bonne partie de la population donc
et essayer d'imposer les choses qui pour
nous nous paraissent tout à fait naturel
est essentielle
là-bas manifestement ça n'a pas eu les
mêmes répercussions même si des progrès
ont été faits je veux dire il faut pas
totalement négligé et d'ailleurs ce
convoi de ces derniers jours montrent
même des afghans et des afghanes qui qui
ont adhéré
à cette idée que les jeunes filles
peuvent aller à l'école peuvent faire ce
qu'elles veulent dans leurs vies ne sont
pas acceptées a obligé d'accepter les
mariages forcés il ya quand même eu des
progrès
en afghanistan pendant longtemps il des
produits aussi haut niveau
en termes d'augmentation du niveau de
vie c'est un des pays les plus pauvres
les afghans avaient un meilleur pouvoir
d'achat si je puis dire après l'invasion
américaine et au cours des vingt
dernières années ça risque de changer
assez radicalement dans les prochains
mois
et je pense que
je pense qu'il faut qu'on coller à
l'esprit
nous occidentaux à le fait que peut-être
nos valeurs elles sont pas aussi
universel que ça c'est un peu déroutant
à accepter surtout à une époque où on a
l'impression notamment à travers
l'information qui circule très vite les
réseaux sociaux que tout le monde sur la
planète aspirent au même chose mais il
ya des réalités qui sont un petit peu
différente il faut l'accepter et pas
nécessairement s'y résigner je veux dire
on peut toujours pas dévié de l'aide au
développement
le travail des ong
l'éducation
germé vous faire germer les
l'espoir de sociétés plus ouvertes même
dans un pays comme l'afghanistan mais si
vous essayez de faire ça à l'afghanistan
c'est probablement l'un des pays les
plus difficiles à où vous pouvez vous
pouvez le faire s'il veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas essayer de le faire mais voilà
on y est on a peut-être pas les
meilleurs outils pour le faire et alors
c'est surtout pas une intervention armée
qui va y contribuer
que ce soit l'afghanistan ou l'irak ont
bien démontré que cette idée farfelue
des néoconservateurs d'implanter la
démocratie par le bout des armes ne peut
pas ne peut pas fonctionner bon et vous
allez me dire que la démocratie quand
même une créature une création très très
très fragile
même dans les démocraties occidentales
ou nécessaire levée aux dernières
élections américaines comment tu vois
que ça c'est sur un fil exactement ce
match on essaie d'implanter quelque
chose comme ça quand la 60% de la
population qui est tout le temps complet
tu parlais des progrès que ut au niveau
nouveau la place de la femme dans ce qui
était ici c'est la tragédie l'impression
dit que ces jeunes femmes là maintenant
qu'ils ont grandi dans
les manades en année dans un kaboul
relativement plus ouvert et accepte
acceptant puis que ces femmes non plus
aller à l'école puis le jour au
lendemain se faire enlever les droits
c'est ce qui crève le plus le croquant
corgan seul à l'international depuis les
témoignages qu'on voit justement de ces
femmes là les images d'aidé
qui se font peinture et les visages de
femmes de la place publique on your du
nord d'ouvrir son intérieur qui sait
c'est difficile de je comprends qu'on le
regarde avec nos yeux d'occidentaux
selon nos valeurs occidentales mais
difficile de pouvoir se commun comme une
tragédie ndt ah oui et c'est une
tragédie pour les femmes les jeunes
filles afghanes au premier rang et d'où
cette volonté qui quasiment désespéré a
quitté le pays bon on voit beaucoup les
gens qui voient à l'aéroport et qui
espère un monter à bord d'un des
derniers avions et qui restent ont la
vie qu'elle aime le canada a annoncé
aujourd'hui avoir fini ses opérations
d'évacuation il reste quand même pas une
semaine pour celle des états unis a
priori mais aussi beaucoup de gens des
afghans qui ont entrepris de quitter
leur pays à pied par la voie terrestre
notamment en passant par l'iran avec
l'espoir d'aller
peut-être rester en iran vous allez me
dire la place des femmes en iran pas non
plus voilà joie mais à traverser pour
aller jusqu'en turquie et peut-être
venir là
jusqu'en europe alors ce qui était très
intéressant
c'est que au cours d' depuis les dix
dernières années en fait les femmes
afghanes en
était de plus en plus pessimiste quant à
l'avenir du pays ça aussi ça peut
expliquer pourquoi les talibans et
autant de facilité à revenir parce que
face à la corruption et l'inefficacité
du régime à lorsque notamment l'institut
galope poser des questions posées des
sondages en afghanistan on voit depuis
dix ans maintenant que autant les hommes
que les femmes dans le pays et surtout
en fait les femmes devrais je dire
était très pessimiste sur
lorsqu'on pose la question pensez vous
que le pays est à 5 ans va dans la bonne
direction
une majorité d'à peu près deux tiers
disent ou disait de façon assez
systématique d'une année sur l'autre ben
ça va pas dans la bonne direction
donc
et on dit tout à l'heure
beaucoup de personnes veulent quitter le
le territoire beaucoup d'afghans veulent
quitter leur territoire
l'afghanistan est sur le podium des pays
qui aimait le plus de réfugiés donc qui
crée le plus de réfugiés dans le monde
avec la syrie et le venezuela
est ce un pays d'émigration
l'afghanistan depuis une quarantaine
d'années d'accord même vingt ans de
présence occidentale avec toutes leurs
missions qui avait ça ralentit les les
flux migratoires au départ d'afghanistan
mais ça les a pas totalement taris
oriana comme voulu revenir parce qu'en
général les réfugiés l'essentiel des
réfugiés se quittent un pays il vend
dans les pays limitrophes parce que avec
90 95 % de ces réfugiés qui ont l'espoir
de revenir dans leur pays d'origine
mais là évidemment cet espoir là il va
être ténue pour les les femmes afghanes
est il viable et là où c'est difficile
pour lui pour les occidentaux
c'est comment vous réagissez pas part à
ce non pas d'un point de vue de
politique intérieure et tout le débat
sur l'immigration c'est pas du tout ça
là
le point sur lequel je veux attirer
l'attention c'est par rapport au
développement à long terme de ces pays
c'est bien d'accueillir les gens qui
veulent partir une obligation
internationale
d'accueillir des réfugiés qui sont
menacés dans l'intégrité physique la vie
est menacée dans leur pays
d'origine et en plus souvent cette
immigration là elle peut créer une
richesse pour les pays d'accueil
d'accord il ya beaucoup d'exemples
grandes entreprises créées par des
migrants notamment aux états unis il
faut leur venir en aide sauf que à plus
long terme mais vie privée
un pays comme l'afghanistan de sa
principale ressource
et c'est tout un équilibre à voir ça
s'applique à la vie à distance
s'applique à plein notre pays
où la situation politique sociale
économique sanitaire enfin tout ce que
vous voulez sécuritaire fait que les les
gens veulent partir mais
qui reste pour reconstruire le pays
seulement 2,5 exactement
restait juste je sais 5,6 göttingen dans
le vent salle de contrôle qui combine un
bon pays gagne je n'ai promis qu'ils
partent surtout plus les intellectuels
c'est les gens qui ont peut-être un peu
plus de moyens et d'éducation qui ont et
qu'ils ont le luxe de pouvoir
partir finalement exactement exactement
quand les moyens financiers déjà de
pouvoir prendre des gens importants
l'économie du exact exacte des gens
aussi quand les réseaux pour partir
parce qu'il faut connaître le monde il
faut être connu
apparemment pour pouvoir partir ça crée
évidemment des des inégalités des
pourquoi on prend par exemple quelqu'un
qui a une bonne relation avec justin qui
connaît un militaire ou un diplomate
canadien qui a pu partir et le voisin
qui est dans une situation qui connaît
pas les lui peut pas partir
c'est ça c'est assez tragique et il faut
faire attention que thelma s'était fait
un peu de d'aspirateurs qu'on peut avoir
un peu on vient vampiriser les
ressources d'un pays encore une fois
c'est pas évident je veux dire quand on
voit des images comme inscrire la
réaction humaine et humanitaire première
c'est à dire il faut absolument aider
ces gens là et tout à en parler
d'opinion publique américaine à l'heure
actuelle l'opinion publique américaine
est un peu déçu de la pression des
pilotes a géré le retrait mais vous avez
huit américaine sur dix qu'ils soient
républicains et démocrates assez rare de
nos jours qui disent d'écouté il faut
aider ces gens à partir or il faut faire
preuve d'humanité
cc c'est un enjeu qui est extrêmement
complexe le cpie kiki qui au final on
dirait que comme pas de bonne réponse
mais c'est se fixer pour acheter là
dessus c'est que
de l'extérieur une dot en occident on
voit ces images la pause il faut aider
ces gens l'offre à quelque chose mais au
final en tant qu'individu absolument
rien qu'on peut faire c'est pour pour
aider ces gens le rapport à port se
présenter aux urnes fit voter pour un
gouvernement qui fait la meilleure chose
selon toi même tu apparais s'est ouvert
après notre ouverture et c'est la seule
chose qu'on peut faire mais sinon
concrètement pour aider les femmes à
présentement en afghanistan - mais mis
mon action illimitée là quand même oui
oui je je je vous décourage de vouloir
aller faire un tour en afghanistan
sortir du mans c'est pas la bonne idée
alors à un niveau très modeste on peut
peut-être faire des choses mais très
modestes qui peuvent avoir un effet
déjà signifié notamment dans les
enquêtes d'opinion dans les sondages
koné favorable à l'accueil de réfugiés
ça peut avoir qu'un impact sur les
décideurs politiques
si des majorités écrasantes là comme aux
états unis 80 % disent on est d'accord
pour l'accueil de réfugiés le
gouvernement fait probablement plus
ouverts acquérir des délais réfugiés on
peut aider des ong qui oeuvre
qui lavera sabourin les dons financement
des ong sont toujours à la recherche de
financement ça peut être
une façon d'aider est peut-être la
meilleure façon à long terme c'est de
pas oublié parce que le drame notamment
des notamment de l'afghanistan en fait
c'est que à la fin des eaux tout début
des années 90
en premier lieu les américains sont les
oubliés
les américains utilisent l afghanistan
pour embêter union soviétique dans le
contexte de l'affrontement de la guerre
froide
sont dit on va faire vivre aux
soviétiques en afghanistan
toute la peine que nous on a vécu au
vietnam qu'auparavant et ça a fonctionné
parce que l'afghanistan quelque part à
contribuer à l'effritement de l'urss et
donc à la chute de l'union soviétique
quelques mois après le retrait de
des troupes soviétiques d'afghanistan
sauf que une fois que ça ça a été gagné
les américains y bombay
l'afghanistan ça nous intéresse plus on
ferme les yeux et d'ailleurs il y avait
un très bon film avec tom hanks et julia
roberts je pense
sur l'engagement américain en
afghanistan pendant les années 80 la
guerre selon charlie wilson charlie
charlie wilson soit le titre original
est à la fin du film a donc charlie
wilson qui était un représentant à la
chambre des représentants au congrès à
washington qui était très intéressé par
la situation afghane il dit de façon
carrément que prémonitoire ai dit mais
pourquoi on n'accorde pas quelques
milliers ou de millions de dollars pour
rester en afghanistan puis aidé à créer
des écoles ou faire du développement
alors qu'on l'a exploité leur territoire
pendant dix ans dans notre combat contre
les soviétiques
ça serait de l'argent bien investi puis
se vide qu'on va laisser ça se
retournera pas contre
le film a été réalisé après 2001
évidemment mais s'agit peut-être un peu
subliminal et il faudrait pas reproduire
la même chose maintenant c'est à dire
bon on a fait ce retrait là on a arraché
le pansement de façon très violente
ça nous a traumatisés on n'aime pas ça
les images qu'on voit et tout ça on va
débattre sur la popularité de maiden est
ce que ça va miner les états unis ou pas
leur crédibilité ça c'est vraiment une
des pages secondaire à mon sens parce
que les états unis s'en remettront je
veux dire c'est pas grave encore une
fois pour les états unis et c'est pas
grave non plus probable des nations sont
être un peu provocateur là dessus mais
par contre ils font des passes 10
rebonds mais voilà on tourne la page et
on oublie la l'afghanistan parce que ça
pourrait venir nourrir
ça va ça pourrait venir nous hanter de
deux nouveaux alors baden a promu quand
même dans ses déclarations depuis le 15
août d'être très ou de faire en sorte
que les états unis restent attentifs à
la situation en afghanistan et quand il
dit attentif à la situation en
afghanistan c'est essentiellement
surveillez qu'une organisation
terroriste ne trouvent pas refuge et de
planifier des attentats un martyr das
qu'ils ont pas fait on a des années 90
ce qui serait un bris de la promesse des
talibans dans l'accord qu'ils ont signé
ouais puis donc qui pourrait être sa
prêtre m'a ramené un retour des troupes
en afghanistan ou si jamais il y avait
il y avait ce bris le
oui
si les taliban respecte pas cet
engagement là on peut imaginer que les
américains
vont les frapper un nom de marc
thériault un petit peu plus peut-être
pas de débarquer avec des troupes
terrestres
parce qu'abidal tant qu'il est à la
maison blanche on peut imaginer qu'il
n'aura pas envie de lancer des dés
grande invasion terrestre parce que la
population américaine n'a pas envie mais
utiliser des moyens aériens comme les
états unis ne vont pas remonter plus
loin mais depuis les années 80 lorsqu'il
ya des groupes terroristes dans tel ou
tel pays n'hésitent pas à bombarder ils
l'ont fait en libye
il avait fait en irak
ils ont fait un organiste sommes
évidemment et là il pourrait très bien
le refaire alors avec une efficacité qui
reste limité parce qu'en général
c'est plus calme c'est pas chirurgicale
alors même si aujourd'hui avec les
drôles on peut être plus précis mais le
problème c'est qu'en général ils et les
groupes terroristes sont pas totalement
tous idiots et
cesser de se protéger par rapport à ça 1
d'accord ou même de créer des diversions
pour qu'on bombarde des temps de vie des
pad et des infrastructures importantes
et donc
les américains vont devoir garder ils
ont les moyens technologiques un de
surveillance et d'observation pour faire
cela le plus gros problème après c'est
de garder
l'attention si vous voulez
intellectuelle sur sur ça l'appareil de
sécurité nationale aux états unis lé tri
cran il est très puissant il a beaucoup
moins mais son attention elle change ah
voilà on disait tout à l'heure quand ils
sont passés de l'afghanistan à l'irak a
en 2002 2003 l'afghanistan est été
oubliée là ils veulent se recentrer
absolument sûr la chine et dans une
certaine mesure sur la russie donc si
vous faites plus attention à d'autres
menaces elles peuvent revenir un peu
comme l'oeil de seront dans le fond le
qui regarde tout le temps une affaire à
foix justement cela
peut paraître paradoxal pour un pays
comme les etats-unis on imagine que son
hyper puissants ils ont tous les moyens
qu'ils veulent c'est vrai mais la
tension elle dépend aussi de l'attention
des principaux dirigeants politiques et
faut jamais oublier comme présidente des
états unis même s'ils disposent de
moyens extraordinaires la politique
étrangère c'est un seul de ces dossiers
sur son bureau et c'est pas
nécessairement là c'est pas
nécessairement le plus important est
aujourd'hui la crédibilité des états
unis
puisque je l'évoquais il ya un instant
elle dépend pas de ce qui se passe en
afghanistan ou de la façon dont le
retrait s'est fait bien ou pas bien même
s'il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent que
voilà c'est la catastrophe
cette crédibilité là elle dépend de
l'arsenal nucléaire américain
elle dépend de la vitalité de l'économie
américaine et elle dépend de l'état de
santé de la démocratie américaine
et ce dernier point là on l'évoqué tout
à l'heure on a vu notamment les
événements du 6 janvier 2021 au capitole
en tout cas elle va pas très bien là
à l'inter et biden a probablement en
tête cet aspect là et il veut énormément
investir et d'ailleurs ces projets de
lois les plus importantes veulent
investir dans l'économie et refaire en
sorte que la société américaine elle
soit plus égalitaire pour que la
démocratie américaine soit en meilleure
santé et que là les états unis
retrouvent un peu leur
leur lustre sur sur sur la scène
internationale c'est pas partant de
kaboul dans les conditions plus ou moins
réussie que la crédibilité d'être
affectés ou amélioré à s'auto en début
de mandat comme seul homme dans trois
ans et demi aux personnes vont passer à
autre chose je
connais ça l'est justement la tension
très vision tunnel sur certains sujets
prennent maintenant trois ans et demi
alors c'est sûr que les opposants à
baïda dans l'est républicain à mayran il
va le ramener tout le temps ainsi vous
souvenez de ce qui s'est passé en 2012
est en 2012 là avec
l'assassinât ou la mort de l'ambassadeur
américain en libye
suite à une attaque d'un groupe
terroriste je pense que j'ai pu lire à
quel groupe
les républicains ont tellement insisté
sur ça pendant des années pendant la
campagne électorale de 2012 mais même
essayer de marquer des points contre
hillary clinton pendant la campagne
électorale de 2016 donc en 2022 pour les
élections de mi mandat et en 2024 pour
les prochaines présidentielles
c'est sûr il devrait en entendre parler
enfin il devrait essayer de il devrait
essayer
de
de l'exploiter mais il ya des éléments
historiques qui sont très intéressants
lorsque on essaye de dire que par
exemple la dans le feu de l'action la
présidence by day ne va pas survivre à
cette débâcle afghane il ya trois cas
historiques qui sont assez intéressant
cet égard là et qui montrent en fait
l'homme versent des présidents en
exercice ont pu survivre à ce qui avait
été perçu à l'époque comme le pire échec
de la politique américaine le premier
c'est quand même john kennedy après la
débandade de la baie des cochons en 1961
à cette tentative de renverser le régime
de fidel castro à cuba avec des
supplétifs cubase avait totalement
échoué
on disait donc début de présidence un
peu voilà à kennedy poussé à annuler il
va payer le prix y est là il a assumé
pleinement et en fait les enquêtes
d'opinion montrent qu'il avait gagné des
appuis au sein de la population
américaine malgré cette débâcle là à le
deuxième exemple c'est celui de et pas
nécessairement dans l'ordre
chronologique celui de ronald reagan
après l'attentât du drakkar en octobre
83 au liban
donc les américains étaient intervenus
dans la guerre civile libanaise
c'est l'un des pires attentats contre
les forces américaines plus de 230 morts
et quelques mois plus tard en avril 84
il décide de se retirer et évidemment ça
relance le conflit civil au liban et là
tout le monde le premier la débandade la
fin de l'administration reagan en
novembre 84 il est réélu avec une
majorité extraordinaire
à la maison blanche est le dernier
exemple parce qu'on a beaucoup fait la
comparaison est donc fini sans lui c'est
l'analogie avec saigon en 1975
enfin on se souvienne cette image d'un
hélicoptère qui quitte le toit de
l'ambassade américaine donc au sud du
vietnam et on l'a mis beaucoup de
comparaison ces derniers jours avec des
ils avions hélicoptères qui quittent
kaboul gerald ford qui était le
président à l'époque de cette débandade
là
il n'a pas été élu
après en 76 mais cet épisode là n'a pas
entamé sa cote de popularité
gerald ford au contraire sa cote de
popularité elle a augmenté
alors je dis pas que byden va s'en
sortir aussi bien que ses trois
prédécesseurs là et d'ailleurs les
sondages en ce moment montrent que
pratique à la main et de
ce problème là ce qui est un peu
compliquée à évaluer quand même c'est
que ça se cumule avec d'autres éléments
pour bynum s'est peut-être pas que là le
retrait d'afghanistan qui un peu nuit en
ce moment sa cote de confiance son taux
d'opinions favorables c'est aussi la
résurgence du corps au navire sera la
crise le vide aux états unis à une
incertitude sur l'économie et sur ses
ambitions de réforme sociale donc mais
il n'est pas voué à être le président
d'un seul mandat ou peintres
indépendants à cause de l'existence vous
disiez tout à l'heure la population
américaine même n'est pas très content
de la façon dont ça se passe est facile
d'être un gars là est fatigué hier
tiendra peut-être pas de temps rigueur
que ça il faudrait pas que l'afghanistan
redevienne et une base pour une
organisation terroriste qui d'ici 2022
2024 qualifiant l'attentât contre les
états unis
pour l'applaudir sur rappaz des faits en
fait tu t'es trompé mais non il y avait
un bémol ça n'aura pas d'effets ici
merci beaucoup bienvenue nous éclairer
puis c'était vraiment super on a
énormément rca où c'était super le fun
jeu j'aurais continué pour un autre
merci d'avoir écouté ce podcast jusqu'à
la fin de ce pas que vous avez apprécié
la conversation ça prouve que vous êtes
de réelles fans de conversation il
s'enfile pas de casser on vous remercie
vraiment
beaucoup si vous voulez avoir plus de
contenus plus de conversations sur
pétillante que ça se passe hier sur
petra non seulement on met tous les
podcasts en ligne au moment où est ce qu
on les tourne donc on a beaucoup de
semaine d'avant sur le pétrole mais on
fait aussi des encore moins de filtres
qui sont exclusifs au monde pictural où
est ce que on parle d'homme nicole et
moi de la conversation convient d'abord
parce qu'on met un peu plus en
profondeur dans certains sujets qu'on
voulait aborder ou qu'on a abordé
pendant le podcast donc allez sur notre
page rituels les le lien vers savoir
dans la description du podcast qui
remercie encore une fois nous avons
écouté jusqu'à la fonte